en este vídeo lo que voy a hacer es
exactamente lo mismo que hice en el
vídeo pasado pero en esta ocasión voy a
hacer un poco más matemático la razón
por la cual quiero meter un poco más de
matemáticas es para que veas la misma
idea claro con una notación un poco más
críptica pero de una forma un poco más
general ok entonces supongamos que en
esta economía en vez de que la
propensión marginal al consumo sea de
0.6 como era antes la apm ce ahora es de
un número en general bueno lo que
queremos hacer en este vídeo es ver cómo
un cambio de gasto de este cuate bueno
para él sería un cambio de gasto pero
para el constructor sería un cambio de
ingreso bueno dado ese cambio y dado
también que aquí tenemos un ciclo verdad
que la economía tiene este ciclo de aquí
entonces cuál va a ser el efecto total
en el producto interno bruto eso es lo
que queremos determinar dejarlo pongo
por aquí entonces déjame ponerlo aquí
como delta ye mayúscula es el cambio
total
en el producto interno bruto vale lo
podemos pensar como gasto como
producción depende de cómo lo pienses
bueno entonces supongamos que te quad el
granjero en vez de gastar mil pesos
vamos a nombrar a lo que se encontró en
el calcetín como delta de cero
esta es la cantidad inicial la del
calcetín del test cambio y en mayúscula
lo podemos pensar como gasto y este cero
este pequeño cero es un indicador de que
estamos en la 0a iteración esto indica
que es el delta inicial y luego conforme
tengamos más iteraciones vamos a ir
aumentando el subíndice vale llegó uno
de 23 etcétera bueno entonces si
pensamos en el cambio total del producto
interno bruto pues va a tener que
considerar esto de aquí antes era mil
pesos ahorita es del talle cero entonces
acá abajo hay que poner del talle cero
pero ahora hay que hacer más cosas
porque el constructor recibió dinero y
tiene una propensión marginal al consumo
de cee entonces de lo que obtuvo va a
gastar ce veces esa cantidad entonces
ahora va a realizar un nuevo gasto
pongamos ley del talle
uno este que el siguiente paso para
incrementar nuestro producto interno
bruto y es igual a cero por lo que
obtuvo o se hace por delta cero
entonces ahora después de nuestra 0a y
nuestra primera iteración el cambio
total que obtenemos es de dejarlo como
por acá pues se no sabes que déjame
ponerlo nada más como del taller 1 y
luego detalle 1 lo voy a poner así que
es lo mismo que se por delta 0 va
parece una anotación muy sofisticada
pero en realidad no estamos diciendo
nada nuevo son las mismas ideas que en
el vídeo pasado ahora este cuate recibió
ce del talle cero verdad que es lo mismo
que del talle uno otra vez tiene una
propensión marginal al consumo de ce que
lo que estamos suponiendo y entonces va
a gastar cbs es eso entonces ahora va a
estar va a tener un gasto con el
constructor con este color desde el
talle 2 que es lo mismo que se por delta
entonces es más delta jet2 estoy acá es
otro incremento pero observa que cada
vez se van haciendo más y más chiquitos
y para no olvidarnos cuánto vale aquí
ponemos que del talle 2 es lo mismo que
ese por delta y 1 que también es lo
mismo porque detalla 1s por detalles 0
es lo mismo que se x del talle 0 y
entonces toda esta expresión es
exactamente lo mismo que se cuadrada por
delta de 0 ok estoy acá es por del talle
y acá es del talle cero verdad aquí está
la cuenta final la que va a ser en
limpio ok entonces podemos seguir
haciendo esto verdad si ahora el
constructor obtiene esta cantidad de
dinero y gasta cbs eso con el granjero
entonces ahora tenemos un detalle 3ds
veces lo anterior que sería sea el jugo
pobre del talle cero y podemos seguir y
seguir podemos sumar y sumar una
infinidad de veces cada uno de estos
términos se hace más pequeño de forma
que cuando sumamos todo esto verdad
vamos a suponer lo esperar que se está
entre 0 y 1 para que todo esto funcione
se está entre 0 y 1 obviamente cuando
alguien no tiene dinero pues va a gastar
un poquito verdad no se va a quedar todo
y no va a gastar todo lo que tiene
entonces su propensión marginal al
consumo pues no es 1 porque si gasta
todo está feo y tampoco pueden gastar
más de lo que obtiene entonces vamos a
suponer que está entre 0 y 1 y entonces
esta es exactamente la misma idea que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado pero déjame
hacer esto en general va entonces todo
esto es el cambio en el producto interno
bruto verdad del talle mayúscula es como
el empujón causado por el empujón
inicial
y de aquí actualizamos el empujón
inicial del talle 0 dejalo como en otro
color para que se vea más bonito aquí
tenemos del talle 0 del talle 0 del
talle 0 todo esto de acá son del talle
ceros recuerda que ya se ve 0 pero es
muy complicado decir ya su 0 si vas
factor izamos del talle 0 tenemos que el
cambio total en el producto interno
bruto en la producción o en el gasto es
igual a después de factorizar es igual a
detalles 0 x y vamos a ver qué nos queda
al principio nos queda un 1 verdad aquí
del talle 0 nos hace 11 aquí queda una c
luego tenemos que sumar se cuadrada más
sea el cubo más y así sucesivamente muy
bien en el vídeo pasado te dije que toda
esta expresión se iba a simplificar a 1
entre 1 - entonces toda esta parte todo
lo de aquí dije que es uno entre 1 c
bueno pero a lo mejor no está satisfecho
con eso y como este es el vídeo
matemático nos conviene hacer las
cuentas veamos entonces de dónde sale la
formulita bala de 1 / 1 c ahora no
quiero meter demasiadas variables pero
me llamara a esto x entonces le ponemos
que x x es toda esta expresión de por
acá 1 c más se cuadrada más sea al cubo
más y así sucesivamente y fíjate el
truco consiste en multiplicar esta
expresión por c y entonces qué sucede si
consideramos c x déjame ponerlo en otro
color
qué pasa con c x pues esto de aquí sería
igual saber todo esto se multiplica por
cada sumando entonces aquí ese aquí este
cuadrado más sean cubo más sea la cuarta
más y así sucesivamente ok y mirad qué
sucede ahora si restamos esto de esto
voy a poner una raya para hacer la resta
vamos a restar los lados izquierdos es x
men x y obtenemos x menos c x
a lo mejor debería usar el color rosa -
quien creo que borre el color rosa bueno
con blanco menos x esto de aquí es igual
y en el lado derecho fíjate que sucede
pues aquí muchos términos se cancelan
estas c se cancelan déjame tacharlas con
otro color las c cuadradas también se
cancelan las se cúbicas también la será
cuarta también y como vamos hasta
infinito todo se cancela excepto el 1 y
nada más queda este 1 de aquí entonces
eso está muy padre aquí tenemos un 1 es
un truco súper padre actualizando el x
por acá es x por 1 c es igual a 1 y
ahora sí podemos dividir ambos lados
entre 1 y obtener que x es uno entre 1 -
esto está súper vale x es esta expresión
de acá y entonces esta expresión es
igual a 1 entre 1 - c estoy acá está muy
bueno verdad lo que acabo de demostrar
bueno lo que acabamos de demostrar es
justo lo que te dije en el vídeo pasado
es decir que el cambio total en el
producto interno bruto esto que habíamos
escrito por acá verdad esta expresión es
igual al cambio inicial al empujoncito
que le dimos que aquí le pusimos del
talle cero que es
el gasto inicial que hizo el granjero
cuando el gasto del granjero o bien el
ingreso inicial del constructor entonces
el cambio total es ese cambio inicial
por esta expresión de aquí a la cual le
pusimos el multiplicador y esto de aquí
está bien padre esta expresión está en
función de c y c es la propensión
marginal al consumo esto de aquí déjame
lo pongo de alguna forma como lo
escribiré pues no lo voy a escribir así
entonces el cambio total de nuestro
gasto agregado o nuestro ingreso
agregado o como quieras pensarlo va a
ser igual al cambio inicial x vaya
sorpresa el multiplicador y otra vez
este multiplicador está en función de la
propensión marginal al consumo entonces
esta expresión de aquí es nuestro
multiplicador multiplicador
multiplicador y esto de acá es nuestro
cambio inicial ahora nada más para ver
que cuadran las cosas vamos a verificar
las cuentas del último vídeo en este
teníamos que la propensión marginal al
consumo era de punto 6 entonces se era
igual a 0.6 nuestra detalle 0 nuestro
gasto inicial era de 1000
y vamos a ver cuánto nos da si ponemos
puntos 6 aquí obtenemos 2.5 y es el
mismo multiplicador como aquí también es
1000 entonces a final de cuentas
obtenemos el mismo aumento del pib que
en el vídeo pasado bajo los padres que
ahorita tenemos una fórmula más en
general espero no haberse enredado mucho
con la anotación y bueno la mala noticia
es que en otros textos va a haber
notaciones distintas pero bueno espero
que esto te haya sido de ayuda